i've got my driver's license last week  when you see somebody like olivia  rodrigo who had one of those years where  they had a song that shook the world and  their life changed forever do you see a  little bit of yourself  [Music]  absolutely it's so nice to see  like a younger female artist  singer songwriter putting out music and  it doing so well and and reaching such a  wide audience  [Music]  with olivia everyone loves her of all  ages and i think also at that age you  know really going through a lot as a  young woman and experiencing like  heartbreak and love for the first time  and those types of raw emotions  [Music]  what's so great about billy olivia  writing at such a young age it's so real  and raw and new to them and that they're  hitting an audience it's also like that  for the first time and people can relate